en este vídeo vamos a hacer un par de
ejemplos para revisar rectas paralelas y
perpendiculares de modo que tenemos
paralelas y perpendiculares y por
supuesto que también hay rectas que no
son ni paralelas ni perpendiculares y
para revisarlo brevemente por si nunca
lo has visto las rectas paralelas nunca
se intersectan entonces déjenme dibujar
unos ejes estos son mis ejes coordinados
este es mi eje x este es mi eje y si
esta es una recta que estoy dibujando en
color rojo una recta paralela a esta se
verá así no es la misma recta pero tiene
exactamente la misma pendiente si ésta
se mueve una cierta cantidad si este
cambio en yes sobre el cambio en x es
igual a una cierta cantidad este cambio
en g sobre el cambio en x es esa misma
cantidad y esa es la razón por la que
nunca se intersectan de modo que tienen
la misma pendiente las rectas paralelas
tienen la misma pendiente las rectas
perpendiculares dependiendo de cómo
quieras verlo son todo lo contrario
digamos que esta es una recta una recta
perpendicular a esta no sólo lo va a
inter secar sino que la va a inter secar
en un ángulo recto en un ángulo de 90
grados y no lo voy a demostrar aquí de
hecho ya lo demostré en la lista de
reproducción de álgebra lineal pero la
pendiente de una recta perpendicular
digamos que esta recta que tenemos aquí
esta recta amarilla tiene una pendiente
igual a m luego esta recta anaranjada
que es la perpendicular a la recta
amarilla va a tener una pendiente de
menos 1 sobre m las pendientes van a ser
inversas negativas entre ellas ahora
dada esta información vamos a ver muchas
rectas y tratar de descubrir si son
paralelas o perpendiculares o si no son
ni una ni otra para hacer eso debemos
fijarnos en las pendientes entonces
vamos a ver
dicen que una recta pasa por los puntos
4 menos 3 y menos 80 otra recta pasa por
los puntos menos 1 -1 y -2 6 vamos a
calcular las pendientes de cada una de
estas rectas primero voy a hacer esta en
rosa a la pendiente de la primera recta
de la recta 1 le llamaré la pendiente 1
es igual a voy a tomar este como punto
final entonces menos 3 - 0 recuerden el
cambio en g
menos 3 - 0 sobre 4 menos menos 8
esto es igual a menos 3 sobre esto es lo
mismo que 48 menos 3 sobre 12 que es
igual a menos un cuarto dividimos el
numerador y el denominador entre 3 esto
es de la primera recta ahora qué pasa
con la segunda recta en la segunda recta
la pendiente de la segunda recta es
igual a menos uno menos seis sobre menos
uno menos menos dos
- 16 es igual a menos 7 sobre menos uno
menos dos que es lo mismo que menos 12
es igual a 1
entonces la pendiente aquí es menos 7
aquí las pendientes no son iguales de
modo que no son paralelas ni tampoco son
el inverso negativo cada una de la otra
así que no son paralelas ni
perpendiculares ni paralelas y
perpendiculares
entonces estas líneas se intersectan
pero no en un ángulo de 90 grados vamos
a hacer un par de ejercicios de estos
así que aquí tengo una vez más una recta
que pasa por estos puntos y otra recta
que pasa por estos puntos entonces vamos
a ver sus pendientes
cuál es la pendiente de esta recta verde
la pendiente de la recta verde a la que
llamaré la primera recta podemos decir
que vamos a ver el cambio en ge -2 menos
14 sobre ese primero el menos 2 así yare
primero el 11 menos menos 3 de modo que
menos 214 es igual a menos 16 y 1 -
menos 3 es lo mismo que 13 lo que es
igual a 4 esto es igual a menos 4 ahora
cuál es la pendiente de la segunda recta
tenemos que la pendiente de la segunda
recta es igual a 5 - menos 3
ese es nuestro cambio en sobre menos 20
esto es igual a 53 que es igual a 8 y
menos 20 es igual a menos 2 entonces
está también es igual a menos 4 estas
dos rectas son paralelas son paralelas
tienen exactamente la misma pendiente y
los animo a que encuentren las
ecuaciones de las dos rectas y las
grafiquen y verifiquen ustedes mismos si
son rectas paralelas vamos a hacer esta
otra una vez más este es un ejercicio
para encontrar las pendientes así que
esta primera recta tiene estos dos
puntos vamos a encontrar la pendiente de
esta recta que pasa por estos dos puntos
digamos que tres menos menos tres es
nuestro cambio en g sobre tres menos
menos seis entonces esto es lo mismo que
tres más tres lo cual es igual a seis
sobre tres más 6 lo cual es igual a 9 de
modo que la primera recta tiene una
pendiente de 2
cuál es la pendiente de la segunda recta
esta es la segunda recta que pasa por
estos puntos entonces la pendiente es
igual a vamos a ver menos 8 menos 4
sobre 2 - menos 6 cuál es el resultado
menos 8 menos 4 es igual a menos 12 2 -
menos 6 es igual a 2 massey cierto los
negativos se cancelan así que es menos
12 sobre 8 si dividimos el numerador y
el denominador entre 4 esto es igual a
menos tres medios fíjense que estas
pendientes son inversas negativas entre
ellas si hago menos uno sobre dos
tercios esto es igual a menos uno por
tres medios toques es igual a menos tres
medios estás pendientes son inversas
negativas entre ellas intercambiamos el
numerador y el denominador y lo hicimos
negativo y son iguales por lo que estas
rectas son perpendiculares
los animo a encontrar las ecuaciones ya
les ayude a encontrar las pendientes
encuentren las ecuaciones graphic en las
y verifiquen ustedes mismos que son
perpendiculares hasta el próximo vídeo